ich habe euch auf twitter gebeten mir
ein paar fragen zu stellen so mal wieder
so ein entspanntes fuentes die profis
sagen nein im ernst machte ihren eigenen
youtube-kanal wenn ihr so kamera geil
sein
so haben wir dann die frage ihr wart
super kreativ muss ich sagen ich war
sehr erstaunt yorks fragt hast ein
fanshop oder zuvor ein zu erstellen hab
ich noch gar nicht in irgendeiner
richtung gemacht ich mir vorstellen
könnte dass ich vielleicht jetzt bald
etwas raus bringen werde als spinner
schon am arbeiten dadurch gestaltet das
schon die ganze zeit und und überlege
wie man das machen kann gespannt
vielleicht kommt es noch vor weihnachten
laura katharina bezahlst du deine katzen
für ihre tätigkeit vor der kamera nein
natürlich nicht
ich meine die dürfen die gratis bogen
das ist erstmal punkt 1.2 kriegen die
jeden tag ich beste futter was sie sich
vorstellen können also sorry ruhe mehr
als genug interessante frage von sternen
des kicker wenn ein kind zweisprachig
mit einem kind zweisprachig aufwächst in
welcher sprache denkt dann kommt kommt
drauf an dass sie zum beispiel wenn ich
es nach polen gefahren bin dann habe ich
viel auf polnisch gedacht plötzlich also
weil wir in der familie eigentlich viel
deutsch gesprochen haben habe ich nie so
richtig das polnisch kann es schon
ich hatte halt nicht perfekt also man
hört einen sehr starken deutschen akzent
raus und verstehen tue ich alles aber
sprechen
das musst du doch nur für die kamera
gerade
wo du kommst auf meinen schoß anderem
frag deine meinung zu youtube an die
katzen klicks über hilfen klicks durch
katzen funktioniert sabine fragt sind
wir wirklich lila und haben es keine
lila kuh imagine ich bin nach dem dorf
aufgewachsen
wir kinder vom dorf und wissen dass es
keine lila kühe deshalb nein sie sind
nicht wieder
jojo prag wenn du einer beliebigen
fantasiewelt gehen könnte ist in welcher
würdest du geben ganz klar in der welt
von harry potter keine wesentlich
schöner als die weltkarte die welt herr
der ringe ist auch ganz schön habe ich
in dem bis hin zu gefährlich dies zu
krass das ist viele kriege körper das
man bisher dachte mein knie mein knie
welche klischees treffen auf dich zu
fragt klarer ganz klar ich weine voll
viel also ich kann so schnell heute tv
bitz mal sagen das ding ist aber weil es
ja sehr gesund also deswegen vielleicht
das nicht schlimm dass ich meine
denn weinen bringt die seele wieder in
schwung
wie kommst du das jetzt nur zuschauen
janina fragt mein lieblingsort in
hamburg mein lieblingsort in hamburg ist
auf jeden fall planten un blomen planten
un blomen plan plan
liz fragt warum es nicht besetzen wir
haben wie bild das weiß ich auch nicht
keine ahnung wenn jemand die antwort
kennt schreibt für die kommentare wie
hip hop mal fragt was sagen deine eltern
eigentlich zu den videos und schauen
sich die auch an eltern schauen sich
jetzt jedes video von mir als ich
angefangen hab an seit ich belächelt
also ich will nicht an lustig gemacht
aber jetzt wo er seitlich in der video
preis gewonnen hat und seitdem
metternich also auch regelmäßiger die
katzen spielen der gerade sein und das
ist halt alles auch so ein bisschen
ernster wird kohl ja fragt was war dein
schlimmstes schul erlebnis das war ich
glaube im jahr 2000 sind und sechs oder
sieben oder acht also es war auf jeden
fall zur wm ich glaube da war die em in
deutschland und hat deutschland gegen
polen gespielt und polen hat natürlich
gegen deutschland verloren weil polen
eine furchtbare fußballmannschaft hatte
so eine so lala was am nächsten tag in
der schule passiert ist damit hätte ich
auf keinen fall gerechnet
die gis in meiner klasse beziehungsweise
fangen wir euch drei jungs haben
angefangen im kleinbus vor mir zu machen
und sich darüber dass ich mal was machen
dass deutschland halt wieder gegen polen
gewonnen also ich bin nie so stark in
polen aber das war nicht so viel ex
irgendwie das war jetzt so gemeint und
dann war das auch erstmals eine
schulgemeinde es war jemand der schule
gemeint hat auch wenn ich viel bein
ja das ist muss es kaffee fragt wie geht
es dir
mir geht es großartig denn wir haben
diesem wochenende also das was jetzt
gerade war gut für die welt 2 76.000
sich über 76.000 euro eingenommen und es
war so geil einfach wie community dabei
war wie wir da wirklich so viel spaß
hatten und deshalb mal wieder gezeigt
ist dass die reichweite halt auch wurst
für was anderes genutzt werden kann und
ich bin echt froh ein teil davon gewesen
zu sein weil es einfach echt cool so
allerlei fragt haben die katzen schuld
daran zu nein aber ich möchte den
unbedingt welche nähen ich habe schon
jetzt eine nähmaschine bekommen
vorzeitig zu nikolaus bei meiner mutter
dina so gibt irgendwo im internet katzen
maße dass man das land
das wäre toll kkv lieblings videospiel
aller zeiten mein absolutes absolutes
lieblingsspiel aller zeiten ist crash
bandicoot das habe ich damals auf der
playstation 1 nach der playstation 2
gespielt also als kleine mauer waren und
ich heute aber ich habe so lange nicht
mehr gespielt und ich muss es ganz bald
wieder spielen
sie fragt was wolltest du als kind immer
werden ich wollte immer schauspielerin
werden zwar auch mal und dingen bei uns
in der familie übernehmen
die schauspieler und mit der youtube
sache habe ich da was mein ziel erreicht
so halb fabiana fragt wenn du einen
youtuber von youtube verbannen müsstest
wer wäre es glaube das wetter gehe ich
wenn ich auf diesen hate train
aufspringen aber sie geht nur noch auf
die nerven
bis ihr da macht sie mit den lions
schluss jung war zu sehr der
öffentlichkeit kann man verstehen dass
monaten nicht alles geht das auch mal an
die brüche dann könnten sie ihre ihre
trennung und dann aber seien keine zwei
wochen sieht man in snapshot und
instagram unablässig schon wieder ihr
neuendorf wie wir denken lernen doch
daraus dass die beziehung für dich zu
wenn das dann mal irgendwann auch
wirklich was ernstes ist ja dann wird er
auch mal auf fotos auftauchen aber doch
nicht gleich wieder so
warum
ja ja ja ja
annika fragt magst du die barbie filme
ich liebe filme den nussknacker ist
glaube ich mein liebster von den 1
er hat aber die haben ein paar andere
einzelne 12 prinzessinnen den ziemlich
auch turnen tanzen sie man zusammen so
ein kreis klar sei dass man nicht mögen
darf aber ich finde toll die puppen sind
natürlich unrealistisch
natürlich doof ich habe trotzdem gern
mit barbies gespielt schlimmer sind
diese pressefahrt welches vorbild hast
du mein vorbild ist es auf jeden fall
carolin kebekus
als erstes sei die sogenannte regel
gemacht habt auf jeden fall englisch
über das sind beides zwei großartige
frauen die einfach ein schild darauf
geben was
andere sagen die amtierenden machen die
dabei super lustig sind und darin würde
ich halt auch immer gerne kommen ja
meine kette schmeckt lecker masse die
frage inwiefern hat youtube dein leben
verändert youtube hat mein leben ich
habe zwei ich hatte fallen leben und ich
ein anderes leben
via frage wer ist die katzen lady auf
youtube michaela du bist die katzen lady
auf youtube ich würde dir doch niemals
den platz wegnehmen
nix da fragt gibt es homosexuelle
alpakas ja es gibt alles in homosexuell
und mit dieser hoch intelligenten frage
beende ich jetzt mein video und ich hab
euch gefallen wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal
bis dann